[Music]
welcome back to the fifth annual
Halloween special today I am talking
with my really good friend Matt about
saw not a storm of the century
no we're also not talking about blood
lust subspecies three the hell is that
I don't know he just bought cos is cool
for the made to be here background yes
this office had this bookcase and it was
made to be here just for this month the
first saw I saw in Peters was saw six I
haven't seen any of the saws all the way
through it's not the first one TV like
bits and pieces or at her friend's place
never saw it from start to finish and I
think in college one friend was like
it's Halloween you're gonna go seesaw
sticks with me I was like I can see the
other ones like a fucking onslaught and
really liked it
I gotta see the rest of them so I
watched all of them and then saw seven
in theaters and logging a new one so
yeah jigsaw is coming out so that's one
of the reasons we're talking about saw
today as well as the fact that it's
Halloween and saw has basically become
synonymous with Halloween yeah you said
me yeah
the first seven were all released every
Halloween they made one every year
because they're incredibly cheap to make
that's you know this first one though
was very psychological it was more about
using a violent act to preach immoral or
tell a story or make some sort of
emotional impact it wasn't just about
like a really gory trap that jigsaw made
it was more about like hey there's a
couple people here and as a serial
killer he wanted to tell them the things
they were doing wrong in life by
presenting a horrible trap in which they
would have to get out of it that was
also like a metaphor for whatever they
were doing in real life that was wrong
for a while I hadn't seen any of the saw
sequels I had only seen the first one I
remember when it came out it was one of
those like everyone's talking about it I
think it was and I remember pretty much
all my friends were like hey did you see
the saw you know the thing were they
they they torture each other and
eventually became way more into into the
violence and the traps and it sort of
developed this torture porn aesthetic
that I guess James Wan the director and
Leigh Whannell the writer aren't too
proud of they're not very happy with the
fact that this has become another thing
because their original idea was a lot
more of a thriller yeah you can really
tell from sequel to sequel they've tried
to like outdo the previous traps make it
more gross they did something very cool
in the first film that is in my favorite
two horror films The Exorcist Exodus 3
which is like less is more
leave it up to the viewers imagination
so spoilers of course um from the first
saw when Jintao gets his head blown off
his name is detective sting in the Wan
frames it in a way where you don't see
like his head completely like disgusting
and exploited and the sequels they show
it and it's not as effective for me they
do it again for when Kerry Ellis cuts
off his foot or his leg and just cutting
away or just kind to carry he did a
great job to just like like you don't
have to like all you do is show a couple
which they did a couple shots of the saw
touching bone and blood you have to show
like the whole fucking thing they did in
the sequels so yeah it was very
effective because it was very artsy
James Wan did a great job in the first
of all yeah and one of the reasons -
what was their budget was so low that
there were certain things their corners
they had to cut things they couldn't
show they couldn't afford to do a lot of
prosthetics
there were even specific moments where
they had to bring Leigh Whannell in to
like stand in in like close-ups for
various shots they they needed like
there's a shot of one of the people like
entering a building and going like this
with a gun and they cut off his head
like in the frame because actually Leigh
Whannell really I didn't yeah they
filmed so much so quick they didn't have
any exterior shots I wonder how they
even dangler you know got a paycheck
yeah right the budget was like a million
dollars that's how all horror films are
though it's like a million and that
makes Bank like happy deathday or
something it made more money than blade
runner's like
and saw and paranormal activity are like
the two biggest horror franchises that
showed Studios that you can make like a
really successful movie that was
actually pretty good for nothing and it
easily make your money back on just
opening weekend alone like even the car
chase scene and saw is yeah that was
really it was really cheap yeah it's
just like they're just going like this
and it's all sped up that's it's all
black Yesi background lights and fog
yeah I mean there's something to say
about two really creative people who
apparently I guess they were rooming
together when they made the first saw
yeah they're friends and stuff yeah just
coming up with a random concept and
scrounging as much resources as possible
to make something it's really inspiring
actually like it is as a film saw has a
couple issues I've read interviews with
them where they've talked about how they
can barely watch it now because they
just see all the things they want to
change and yeah I know that feeling they
can't look at it without seeing all the
flaws it's like a dual edged sword
because they did a great job by
providing something new and fresh but
then again at the same time we talked
about earlier each film like kind of
regressed and unfortunately launched a
torture porn genre where have you seen
the collection or the collector examine
how about the hostels I've skipped the
house they're not none of those are good
the collection and collector have
Charlie Koster did the music for saga
and star Jang or Josh Stewart who was in
Dark Knight Rises that's weird just wore
that I didn't think about that but uh
they're like five out of ten six out of
ten but like no other torture porn film
in my opinion is good as the first one
probably because they did the artsy
stuff the less is more even if they
didn't have a lower budget the best
movies I've ever seen that have torture
as a theme or the first saw and this
film called the loved ones that was from
the director of the devil's candy okay
that was an actual pretty good torture
movie but the thing that I liked about
saw and why I didn't initially watch it
was because it was so heavily shrouded
by this it's torture it's gross its
disgusting I was like I want to watch
that I'm sure a bunch of people like
hurting themselves yeah so it took me a
few years to actually watch the first
one and I remember being really excited
by the
fact that it is very psychological that
it's really just two men in a room and
you cut back to danny glover and his
investigation but for the most part it's
a mystery about how these people got
there and they have these tiny little
clues that lead them to the eventual
realization at the end and a pretty cool
twist with Tobin Bell standing up
st. game over and sliding the door shut
and like Leigh Whannell is like
horrified faces yeah definitely one of
the most iconic images and the Saw
franchise for sure absolutely that
ending still gets me when Hello Zep
starts playing honestly it's like you
tweeted out the one day like what makes
classic a classic and that is time I
want to say that like the original saw
is like a modern day like horror class
huh because it's like the music I just
said probably my favorite like scores
from Charlie and all of like since
whenever past 20 years for horror films
and he did the rest of the like all
seven I don't know he's doing eight but
all of them great music I don't know how
you think but I think the flow of the
film you talked about Dan Glover stuff
if it's like the subplot is the
flashbacks
I thought the usage of flashbacks in
this phone fucking excellent very
organic how they used it what do you
think yeah I really like the way that
they have the incorporated past stories
with the flashbacks that sort of tie in
to what's happening presently because
often times in movies when they have
flashbacks it just feels like here's
some exposition you might need yeah this
movie it feels really integral and it
feels sort of like a puzzle being put
together yeah which makes sense jigsaw
puzzles instead like at all kind of the
themes of what jigsaw the jigsaw killer
is mixes with the way James Wan tells
his story because it's about a killer
forcing other people to put together the
pieces of their lives that have
according to jigsaw anyway led them to a
bad place
yeah and we get to piece that
information together as viewers yeah
which is exciting
something that wanded interesting with
dr. Gordon Cary Elwes and Adam Leigh
Whannell was he filmed Adam very
handheld and Gordon is very steady to
show like there
personalities because Adam is like
really on edge yeah right um and dr.
Gordon is like oh I'm gonna think
through this they have things out and so
he chose the different camera stuff and
it's funny because the first time I wash
it I didn't notice that and that's
usually something that I would pick up
on like why is he switching so much like
you know cuz usually one Scene picks one
you know camera moving or camera style
and stays with it throughout that whole
ceiling we're gonna have handheld the
whole scene or lockdown the whole scene
but he switches back and forth between
each character to show their personality
state and it's actually kind of seamless
and when I rewatched a second time with
that in mind I was like damn he really
did do that so I like the way Juan
approached this movie it wasn't just
like hey we have a couple people in the
room and we have a couple bloody effects
and this cool concept like you really
the end let's make a lot of money let's
not say anything no they really fucking
tried yeah and they pulled it off I
think I have a couple minor flaws I I
can overlook the low-budget stuff that
wasn't perfect like there's a shot of
Glover and his partner walking up this
stairwell and there's like all this mist
and that's a very like film thing that
happens like hey we'll put some fog on
the ground why is there fog on the
ground in a warehouse you know like it's
just there to look cool but there's a
lot of shots like that in this movie
where they're just using a fog machine
to try to create more atmosphere when
there really wouldn't be fog dancing
around the ground of a warehouse for no
reason at all and sometimes that kind of
stuff in movies it diverts my attention
I also do think Danny Glover's character
is a little underdeveloped I wish there
was a little more for him because his
obsession with with jigsaw I think kind
of it just feels very random and sudden
and I wish there was a little more
development for him maybe a little more
time given to that but again if you
research the the problems they had
filming this
they had like no time they were so
high-strung when it came to their
schedule they filmed it in such a quick
amount of time I think I have like a
couple nitpicks that don't take off
points for like you said and then I have
one that I do take off of one point for
the little bit pics is like they just
every time they through something that's
like never by the person there's always
like way over there like
not played football or baseball or
anything throw the tape recorder throw a
tape recorder it's over there yeah yeah
it happens all the time
oh my god this one's hilarious
so when zip and Glover are shooting each
other like pretend this is like the
pillar Glover is hiding behind like he
shoots and he's out and he says like
what the fuck what no one says that when
you're you you know when you're gonna be
out when you're out you don't you go you
go like fuck or damn it you don't go
what the fuck it was so funny and that
you know not taking professionally a cop
also we talked about before we start
recording this movie needs a remaster
these are the blu-ray the blu-ray is not
good it's very dirty yeah it needs a
cleanup there's a lot of grain I like
film grain but there's dirt like on the
gray yeah it's different because their
brain is like an aesthetic choice yeah
like digital is very clean there's like
hairs but yeah it's it needs a restore
it really does so one thing I have
written down here is a modern epic I
don't take off points for I don't know
if anyone else maybe some of their nets
talked about it there try to saw the
chain but they don't try to saw the pipe
the two locks have smaller or I have
written down like there's like valves
and shit behind Gordon just take the
valve off and that's a spike and he just
like jamming up the lock and yeah try to
break the lock like they don't even try
the pipe either like a pipe yeah it's
always like it's not there to chain the
foot like hmm do you think the people
participating in the game deserve to be
participating in the game what do you
think they've made a mistake big enough
to be there yeah you know it's I feel
like the sequels got so big into like
you're a terrible person in health care
you're a racist you know like all these
really horrible things yeah go back and
watch the first one you're like yeah I
think like maybe he's made some mistakes
yeah he doesn't have to necessarily cut
off his foot I know that's the thing
maybe there's you know this sequel
spoiled me but I'm looking at all of
them like Zep what the fuck did he do to
deserve to be poison and then have to
forced to kidnap somebody now I think
Amanda druggie maybe mark she like lied
and like was making money from work like
does he deserve you burned alive no I
feel like perhaps Juan and Whannell were
setting up jigsaw to be more of a
legitimate psychopath yes in the first
and the sequels took him and more of
this like methodical I have a plan type
thing yeah obviously has a plan in the
first and he's thought it all out very
clearly but I think he was a little more
psychopath enjoying the whole killing
aspect or forcing other people to kill
in the first their mutilated bodies you
yeah and in the second and third and the
fourth it became more of like a you have
a problem I have a problem with you
don't play a game you're a racist you're
a horrible health care minor I'm going
to kill you you know and so I can see
why you'd say that yeah and I think I
have answer for that too
like what are you wearing right now like
that's a t-shirt with Billy on it
yeah and jigsaw and Billy in the whole
like you know symbol has become like
this own thing and it's marketable so
let's make him a good guy by killing bad
people rather than killing wishy-washys
you got missions yeah yeah that's
another question I do have with the
entire franchise having watched all
seven who what controls this puppet who
wheels the puppet out who times the jaw
with the words especially after jigsaw
spoilers dies who's doing this there's
really no answer to that question
because everything in and like every
plot point has been answered and like
who set up who put this person that old
man did did it or this it's just like
everything is answered except that so
there really is nothing less in jigsaw
you see Gordon are seeing it there's a
couple moments to that I just think are
funny
there's a few performances like moments
the performances mainly from Cary Elwes
a little over the top yeah she's a
beginning where there's a moment where
he just goes fuck the shit that I think
is so funny yeah
Cary Elwes is I like him you know like
I'm too pretty
Pirate Roberts Princess Bride liar liar
oh the claw not bad
Oh watch yourself it's not call oh oh
the claws coming at you oh you're scared
of a claw your skin of the claw
Jerry for the most part though nitpicks
aside saw is a damn good horror movie
that used an extremely small budget to
utilize a pretty cool concept and
obviously start a huge franchise I'm
gonna give saw a B+ I will give it a 9
out of 10 the first saw and how about
the rest of them how are we gonna rank
those not ratings wise but how about
rankings here's my rank of the saw films
since I mean II would like to know
obviously the first one is the best yep
I say saw one is the best one was low
five I think is the most boring for sure
even though 7 is worse yeah it was at 5
or 7 for the worst I'll probably go 7
worst and the reason I say in the past
that saw is like I would say the best
horror franchise cuz like every single
of them gets a positive score for me
which is a 5 out of 10 or above so yeah
7 + & 5 or fives
so those are the worst ones every
Halloween there's a soft film so they
kind of almost the same as the
paranormal films I think there's one
every Halloween that was their primary
competition right and yeah they were
going head-to-head and when you try to
do one every year and try to you know
make fresh ideas and they're mostly
concerned with grossing people out more
than the previous one and the traps like
you said but there's still that story
there that's why I say it was or is the
greatest horror franchise cuz every
single one of them had like a decent
story behind it because I don't give a
shit about torture porn yeah me neither
and the first saw I think like if you
like me aren't very interested in the
idea of a torture porn like genre check
out the first off you've never seen it
it's it's not like it's reputation no
just only the first one don't check out
the rest on there pretty fuckin gross
yeah it's definitely guys thank you very
much for continuing to watch the
Halloween special please do subscribe to
my friend
Matt's channel it's definitely worth
your time thank you for coming on as
well thank you for having me it's been a
very dope adventure guys thank you once
again and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you